Democrats are calling on some of their
most high-profile star attractions to
try to ramp up support ahead of
Tuesday's voting former President Obama
we've seen on the trail Vice President
Biden taking part
so is Oprah Winfrey senior political
correspondent Mike Emanuel shows us
tonight the right to vote is like like
like the crown we all get to where
Democrats are bringing out major star
power in the closing days of the 2018
campaign Oprah Winfrey's in Georgia
trying to get Stacey Abrams elected as
the first African American woman
governor ACA values are in alignment
with the consciousness of which our
democracy has been founded stepping out
on the campaign trail when some on the
Left would love to see Oprah for
president in 2020 an idea she is
resisting for now her presence and other
Hollywood stars got the attention of
Vice President Mike Pence like I heard
Oprah's in town today
I'd like to remind Stacy and Oprah and
Will Ferrel I'm kind of a big deal to
another potential 2020 candidate former
Vice President Joe Biden continues his
battleground campaign blitz for
Democrats today trying to rescue
endangered incumbent senator Heidi
Heitkamp in North Dakota and testing out
some lines he might use in his own
presidential campaign your silence is
complicity but folks we will not remain
silent but and also offered a fierce
defense of Missouri Senator Claire
McCaskill and attacked Republicans on
protections for people with pre-existing
conditions these guys are either not
telling the truth or they're really
really stupid or both President Obama
has also been out on the trail trying to
rally Democrats and at times taking
veiled swipes at his successor I believe
in a fact-based reality and a fact-based
politics I don't believe in just making
stuff up it is clear that even though
President Trump is not on the ballot in
any of these races these prominent
Democrats are trying to rally support
against him and his policies hoping
their base will send him a message loud
and clear on Tuesday night Brett thanks
Mike